Hola a todos, bienvenidos a este nuevo análisis. A ver, estamos en un momento fascinante y
francamente súper crítico para la logística de última milla en Chile. La nueva Ley 21.719
de Protección de Datos Personales, que entra en vigor en diciembre de 2026, va a marcar
un antes y un después absoluto. Es decir, podemos ir diciéndole adiós a los típicos
trámites burocráticos en papel porque lo que se nos viene encima es una reestructuración
profunda en cómo gestionamos el monitoreo por GPS, la seguridad de los móviles de los
conductores y la minimización de datos. Para que nos hagamos una idea de la magnitud
del cambio, fijaos en este número, 20.000 UTM. Esa es la multa máxima para infracciones
gravísimas bajo la nueva ley. Estamos hablando de una cifra que literalmente puede quebrar
la viabilidad financiera de cualquier operación logística. Y ojo, porque en caso de reincidencia
la broma puede costar entre un 2 y un 4% de los ingresos anuales de la empresa.
Las reglas del juego han cambiado drásticamente.
Y claro, esto nos lleva a una pregunta inevitable. ¿Están nuestras prácticas actuales de rastreo
de flotas creando riesgos financieros masivos sin que nos demos ni cuenta? Pensemos en esa
inercia de monitorear constantemente a los conductores en terreno, o en almacenar historiales
completos de rutas durante años y años. Bueno, pues resulta que toda esa información
ahora está estrictamente regulada. Así que para la gran mayoría de las operaciones
actuales, la respuesta a esa pregunta es un rotundo sí.
Bueno, para entender todo esto paso a paso, echémosle un vistazo rápido a nuestra hoja
de ruta de hoy.
Pasaremos por 1. La nueva ley y sus nuevas reglas.
2. Los límites de la geolocalización. 3. La minimización en la última milla.
4. La seguridad de endpoints móviles. Y finalmente 5. La evidencia operativa y las
sanciones. Arrancamos directamente con el primer punto. Nueva ley, nuevas reglas.
El impacto más brutal de la ley 21.719, con ese límite marcado a fuego del 1 de diciembre
de 2026, es que pasamos del parámetro de la ley 21.719 a la ley 21.719.
El papel a la práctica operativa real. Con la creación de la nueva agencia de protección
de datos, ya no bastará con sacar una política genérica de un cajón y decir, aquí está
todo en orden. ¡Qué va! Van a exigir evidencia operativa. Van a querer ver los registros
de los sistemas y comprobar que los controles técnicos están activos de verdad. Básicamente,
quien no pueda demostrar con evidencias técnicas cómo protege la información en su día a día,
se expone a sanciones inmediatas. Y esto nos conecta directamente con el segundo bloque.
Límites de la geolocalización.
Y ojo a esto, que es interesantísimo. Antes de capturar el primer dato de GPS,
la ley nos impone tres deberes de información explícitos. Primero, el titular tiene que saber
exactamente qué tipo de datos de geolocalización se están recopilando. Segundo, tiene que conocer
la finalidad y cuánto tiempo se van a guardar, por ejemplo, si es para optimizar rutas durante
un mes. Y tercero, y esto es vital, hay que informar si esa ubicación se va a acceder a
terceros, como aplicaciones externas. Sin esto, no se puede hacer nada.
Con estos tres pilares bien asentados, el monitoreo de nuestra flota es ilegal desde
el segundo cero. Pasamos al tercer punto de nuestro análisis, minimización en última
milla. A ver, seamos muy sinceros. Históricamente, en el mundo de la logística, hemos padecido
un poco de síndrome de diógenes digital, esa costumbre tan nuestra de guardarlo absolutamente
todo por si acaso. Pues bien, bajo esta nueva ley, ese hábito es una bomba de relojería.
El paradigma cambia totalmente hacia la minimización de datos. Es decir, ahora solo podemos
la información que sea estrictamente necesaria. Una vez que el conductor entrega el paquete y la
finalidad de ese dato se extingue, esa información tiene que anonimizarse o eliminarse de forma
segura sí o sí. Porque, literalmente, retener información sin un propósito válido, sin un
contrato en vigor o sin el consentimiento explícito es ahora mismo una infracción directa. Imaginemos
por un momento una base de datos llena de pings de ubicación fuera del horario laboral de nuestros
choferes, o historiales acumulados de conductores que ya ni trabajan con nosotros, bajo la lupa de
una auditoría, cada uno de esos registros que guardábamos por si acaso se convierte automáticamente
en una prueba irrefutable de negligencia operativa. Lo que nos yema de cabeza al cuarto punto y un
riesgo crítico para cualquier empresa, la seguridad de endpoints móviles. Fijaos en esta cita porque
dan el clavo totalmente. La mayoría de las infracciones gravísimas no hacen de un dispositivo
perdido sin cifrado o un log que nunca existió. Y es que el hardware que está moviéndose en la
calle todo el día es nuestra mayor superficie de ataque. Las multas millonarias, las multas
millonarias casi nunca vienen de hackers con pasamontañas asaltando nuestros servidores
corporativos, no. Vienen de un escenario aterradoramente cotidiano. Un móvil de empresa
que un conductor se deja olvidado en un asiento, que no tenía la memoria cifrada y del que no
tenemos ni un solo registro para saber qué datos contenía. Un dispositivo sin gestionar en
terreno es, a día de hoy, una multa andante. Pensemos en cómo debe ser el flujo de respuesta
ante incidentes. Ante la pérdida de un móvil, el reloj no perdona a nadie. En el momento en que
se detecta esa pérdida, hay que actuar inmediatamente para evitar que el reloj se
desvanezca, aplicando un bloqueo o un borrado remoto a través de un sistema MDM. A partir de
ahí, se abre una ventana temporal improrrogable de 72 horas para notificar formalmente la brecha
de seguridad a la agencia. Si fallamos en reaccionar rápido o nos saltamos el plazo,
un simple despiste logístico en la calle se convierte en un incumplimiento regulatorio
enorme. Y por eso mismo, para evitar ese desastre absoluto, tener controles mediante plataformas
MDM de gestión de dispositivos móviles es sencillamente innegociable. Necesita
poder certificar que el 100% de nuestra flota tiene el disco cifrado de forma activa, tener
una especie de botón del pánico o kill switch para borrar los datos a distancia de forma fulminante,
mantener un inventario de los dispositivos en tiempo real y, por supuesto, contar con registros
de actividad correlacionados. Sólo de esta manera podremos reconstruir qué pasó realmente
si las cosas se tuercen. Llegamos por fin al quinto y último bloque,
evidencia operativa y sanciones. Seamos muy claros aquí, la agencia de protección de datos no va a
asumir que actuamos de buena fe, van a exigir certezas y pruebas. Si el riesgo que nos están
auditando es la pérdida de un móvil, la empresa tiene que poner sobre la mesa los registros
técnicos que demuestren que el cifrado estaba activo y que el borrado remoto funcionó perfectamente.
Si lo que nos auditan es el monitoreo geográfico excesivo, el equipo legal tendrá que enseñar la
documentación que justifique ese interés legítimo. Así de simple, la evidencia técnica neutralita el
riesgo legal y si no la tienes, lo confirma de pleno. Y es crucial que todos calibremos el
sentido de urgencia con esto. Las multas escalan rapidísimo.
Hablamos de hasta 5.000 UTM para las infracciones leves, 10.000 para las graves y ese tremendo tope
de 20.000 para las gravísimas. Pero bueno, aquí entra en juego un salvavidas muy potente.
El modelo de prevención de infracciones, o MPI. Si podemos demostrar formalmente que ya teníamos
un sistema certificado y respaldado por la tecnología para prevenir fallos,
eso puede ser la gran diferencia entre una amonestación menor y un desastre financiero
total. Para terminar, dejemos en el aire una pregunta que quizá escueza un poco,
¿qué es necesaria? Si la agencia llamara a nuestra puerta para una auditoría mañana por la mañana,
¿podría nuestro equipo de TI demostrar de forma exacta qué dispositivos accedieron a datos
personales de ubicación en las últimas 24 horas? Conseguir ese nivel de trazabilidad lleva su
tiempo. Diciembre de 2026 puede parecer que queda muy lejos, pero dejar atrás las viejas
costumbres logísticas de las que hemos hablado requiere que nos pongamos las pilas hoy mismo.
Muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos en este análisis. El reloj para adaptar
nuestra logística al futuro de la privacidad ya ha empezado a correr.